the speaker one week ago
admitted that she planned to sabotage
and put people out of business simply
for her own political beliefs the
election is over
the time is now to work
and there's an opportunity to get it
done now
i know for more than 40 times you said
no
but today we hope that you will say yes
how many more businesses
have to shutter how many more dreams
have to be shattered
how many more people have to be laid off
before nancy pelosi and the democrats
will act
i'll promise you this the pro
republicans will continue to work in
good faith
just as we put forth bills again and
again
that the democrats have voted no on just
as we worked with the senate
and the white house just as we know
there's an opportunity
to help those who need it the most and
to stop playing politics
with that i want to introduce our whip
steve scalise
[Applause]
thank you kevin i strongly agree with
the comments that our leader just made
when you look at where we are right now
as a country there are
thousands of small businesses that will
spend this weekend trying to figure out
whether or not they're going to be able
to remain open
whether the dreams are going to be
crushed whether the
millions of families who rely on those
jobs
will be able to sustain themselves
through christmas
and during that period for months now
we have been trying to get a vote on a
bill that everybody agrees on
the shabbat bill that jamie herrera
butler has the discharge petition on
is very straightforward there are a lot
of areas where we're still in
disagreement but one area where we all
came together and passed the cares act
was that we need to help those small
businesses who are struggling in those
families
who are wondering whether or not they're
going to have a job to go back to on
monday
we should not be leaving today without
passing that chabot bill
if it was put on the suspension calendar
it would get i would
recommend i'd suggest we would get over
400 votes on that bill
there's wide bipartisan support and yet
as we see speaker pelosi continues to
play games
she admitted the other day as our leader
pointed out
that one of the reasons she won't bring
up bills like this is because she's
waiting for a new president
these small businesses don't have the
time to wait
on a new president or some political
game by the speaker
before they make a decision on whether
or not they will close for good we've
already lost over a hundred
thousand
we've already lost over a hundred
thousand restaurants in america that
will never reopen
a third of every single small business
in the entire state of new york is gone
for good this is a real issue that we
don't have time to wait on
there's a long list of areas where we're
in disagreement every time the president
or secretary mnuchin or mitch mcconnell
put out another
plan on the table all speaker pelosi
does it says no
she doesn't come up with an alternative
they continue to play partisan games and
people's
lives are at stake this game has to end
this game of chicken where hostages are
being taken
and the hostages are america's small
businesses the hostages
are millions of families who just want
to be able to go back to work
the safety protocols are out there
you've had some of the smartest minds in
medicine say there's nothing wrong
with having safety protocols where you
spread people out and have outdoor
dining
and yet you've got some of these
governors across the country that are
telling you you can't go to your local
restaurant
yet they're going to their favorite
restaurant that hypocrisy by these
democrat governors and mayors
has to come to an end it has to end now
how many times have we seen examples of
a governor telling you can't do
something and they're doing it a mayor
telling you you can't do something
and then they're caught doing it a mayor
in cabo
telling you not to hang out with your
family when he's hanging out with his
family
for thanksgiving this is madness this is
insanity and it's not based on science
if it was based on science they wouldn't
be doing it
but they're doing it to control these
small businesses
to crush these small businesses we see
what's going on
everybody says what's going on the
speaker acknowledged it the other day
where see she admits she's playing games
with people because
she wants to wait until a new
president's there she doesn't want trump
to get credit
this isn't about who gets credit it's
about who we can save who we can help
who needs help and we're in agreement on
parts of this
let's pass the bills that we have
agreement on and there are really good
bills that we do
that chabot bill is one example you
could literally save
every small business in this country
that's struggling by bringing up that
bill and it wouldn't even add a dime to
the deficit
that money the 138 billion dollars is
sitting in account frozen
and this isn't a new program this is a
program that's been widely successful
our local banks know who these small
businesses are they need the relief
now they can't wait another week i've
been telling them the majority leader
in our colloquy since september that
this bill is out there and has wide
bipartisan support
and they don't deny it they just point
to all the areas where we disagree while
they're holding these
small businesses hostage the game has to
end
they need to bring this bill to the
floor and we're calling
on speaker pelosi to bring this bill to
the floor to save
all these small businesses who are dying
on the vine and need this relief they
need the relief today
not next week not next month not
whenever pelosi decides to stop playing
games
so that's what we're calling on the
speaker to do bring up the shabbot bill
let's give the relief to these small
businesses who need it now
let's save those millions of jobs so
that they can have their christmas
like we want everybody else to be able
to celebrate this christmas season
and with that i'm going to bring up our
conference chair liz cheney
thanks very much whip scalise you know
every one of us lined up on these steps
every single member on the other side of
the aisle we all represent
thousands thousands of people thousands
of small businesses
who are hurting and when i watch what
speaker pelosi and the democrats are
doing you know
there are many things many times we've
come up here and raised our issues
raised our disagreements with the
speaker in particular
but when i watch this it is a level of
cynicism a level of willingness to
completely ignore the people she
represents
that i have not seen before and i think
it makes absolutely clear
speaker pelosi has been in congress and
has been the speaker
for far too long
the american people deserve a house of
representatives
that is one that will do what is needed
we are in the middle of a pandemic
we have got small businesses across this
nation we have got
ag producers we've got energy producers
we've got restaurant owners we've got
hospitals we've got people
who are suffering and the speaker of the
house
seems to think that this is all about
sitting in back rooms
negotiating deals scoring political
points
when she finally says the quiet part out
loud
and admits she actually is doing that
she actually has delayed
getting help to the american people
because she was waiting to see if joe
biden would get elected president that
is what she's doing
every single american every single
member of this house
particularly every single member of her
party
needs to answer the question and i hope
you all will ask them
do you agree that the speaker of the
house is in the right to continue to
play politics while people's
businesses are suffering while people
are dying
while our hospitals are suffering while
our agriculture industry is suffering
every member of her side of the aisle
has got to stand up and explain
why they think it's okay why they think
these games are all right
people are hurting they need help as our
leader said as our whip said we have the
ability
today right now instead of voting on
bills to legalize marijuana
bills to protect exotic cats put the
bill
on the floor that will help small
businesses and do it
now it'll pass
so we stand together calling on this
body
calling on speaker nancy pelosi to stop
sitting on our hands to stop sitting in
front of a refrigerator with the
expensive ice cream and to help
the american people today with that
i'm going to introduce the republican
leader of our small business committee
mr shabbat
thank you liz um i was the chair of the
small business committee
for two terms and this past term the
ranking member
and uh i'd like to start off by just
saying about half the people who work in
america
work for a small business about 70
percent of the new jobs created in
america
are created by america's small
businesses they're critical
to the american economy when kova 19 hit
earlier in the year this institution
the house the senate together bicameral
and bipartisan republicans and democrats
passed the cares act
and within the cares act the ppp program
the paycheck
protection program it saved over
50 million jobs all across the country
including in my district in this greater
cincinnati
area i visit over 70 of those businesses
i've talked
to businesses who would have gone under
who would have had to get rid of all
their employees
and it's not just the small businesses
again that you're trying to help and you
are
but it's those employees and it's those
families
that they support well unfortunately the
paycheck protection program the doors to
that program
were shut back in august and all we need
to do
is to pass legislation to reopen those
doors to give
small businesses who didn't get an
opportunity to get
one in the first round for whatever
reason or a business
that did but has revenue decreases of 25
meaning they're really hurting and need
another loan give them
access to those loans again we don't
even have to put any more money in the
program there's already approximately
135
billion dollars just sitting there that
we could help
these businesses and save those jobs but
it has already been
mentioned the speaker speaker pelosi
we all suspected that she wouldn't bring
this up for a vote because
even democrats were for it and all the
republicans were for it wouldn't bring
it up for a vote because
if it passed it might help president
president trump in the election we
suspected that
and then she basically confirmed it
recently it's outrageous
to think that politics are standing in
the way of helping those small
businesses
and most importantly helping those
employees
and those families who depend upon this
so i want to thank
our next speaker jamie herrera butler
for her leadership on the rules
committee
and introducing the discharge petition
which would bring my bill
h.r 8265 to the floor and actually put
those democrats
uh who said they'd support it on the
line with
all the republicans and pass this for
those small businesses who so
desperately uh need this so uh jaime
thank you uh to leader mccarthy whip
scalise chair liz and thank you steve
chabot
for your work on the pbp legislation
look we're here because
because we want the families and the
individuals and the businesses
in our districts and across this country
to survive
we want them to thrive but at the very
least heading into hanukkah
heading into christmas we don't want
them sending their team members
into the unemployment line where by the
way
the unemployment benefits are also
stalled this is ridiculous
that's all this is about this is not a
partisan
issue however we're the ones stepping up
saying nancy pelosi
the first ppp bridge worked
please do not let this become nancy
pelosi's bridge
to nowhere we have got to get this
passed
it's important to start by saying the
paycheck protection program
expired august 8th and we knew
months before that the date that it was
going to expire we have known for most
of this year
that this would be a problem
ppp has roughly 135 billion dollars
left sitting there untouched we don't
have to spend new money
we don't have to add more money into
some sort of a supplemental it's
there all we have to do is change the
dates
to allow those loans to be accessed
that's it
and the reason that this hasn't moved is
because it's a political football
nancy pelosi has allowed these
businesses these individuals
these families these single mothers with
children and in clark county and
southwest washington i have over 15 000
single families
she's allowed those people to be a
political football in order to get
different more bigger trillions of
dollars of
more money well what we really need is
this targeted relief we know it's going
to work
in southwest wash in my district alone
this has saved
nearly 95 000 jobs
ninety five thousand jobs that's amazing
over ten thousand businesses have access
these critical for
forgivable loans this again should not
be a partisan football house democratic
leadership has shown that they rather
use
the fate of these small businesses as a
bargaining chip it has been admitted
i mean i'm gonna guess most of the folks
here suspected it
but she's admitted it that's the reason
i filed a discharge petition back in
september
so we could finally clear the gridlock
and get those small businesses the
relief that they need
to survive the pandemic this discharge
petition
is really a tool of last resort we know
it
members on both sides of the aisle know
it and they've used it to go to nancy
pelosi and say we're going to do this
unless you break this log jam well i
believe it is time it's well past time
to break this log jam congress must act
now
if we're serious about getting relief to
families individuals
small businesses we have to support this
discharge petition
and get steve chabot's ppp legislation
reauthorized reopened up families
communities
workers uh individuals they need it and
that's why we're here that's what we're
about thank you
and we are going to have representative
wayne luke demire come up next
thank you jamie and thank all of you
being here this morning and our
leadership team for doing a great job of
putting this event together and uh for
uh
representative chabot to put his bill
together and uh representative herrera
butler
for hard work on getting a discharge
petition together
i'm going to be the new ranking member
on on small business i presently
i'm the ranking member on fi the
committee the subcommittee that
the ppp program came through originally
and uh we want to continue to work on
this this is why we're here this morning
this is a very
very important program that has proved
to be effective
that proved to work and yet it's being
held up
for seemingly no reason except politics
which around here seems to be the
course of the day by the speaker you
know back home in missouri
today 520 000 small businesses that
employ
1.1 million people were greeted
this morning by continued nothing they
continue to wake up to the familiar
news that the majority continues to want
to play politics with their lives
the lives of the businesses and lives of
their businesses employees
this is the eighth legislative day since
thanksgiving
that the house has passed two pro and in
that time the house has passed
two bills promoting marijuana and zero
to help the workers who have lost their
livelihoods through no fault of their
own
meanwhile governors on the coast can are
taking a break from their private
dinners and book promotions
to shut down small businesses and
independently owned restaurants
only to watch those customers walk in a
walmart sit down without a mask
and eat a lunch without incident
the hypocrisy of that is is breathtaking
i would say the speaker simply i would
say the secret simply does not
understand
the real world and effects of bad policy
just this week as we've mentioned number
of times here she's proudly announced
that she
knew exactly what she was doing when she
blocked the ppp vote for more than 40
times
over the last several months she was
intentionally increasing the pain
on small business and their employees
with hopes of tanking the economy
and hurting the president's election
chances ladies and gentlemen that is not
leadership that is not serving our
country
that's hurting people the very people we
all came here
to help and should be working hard for
instead of punishing
leadership is putting the pizza shop
owner in one of my districts
counties in saint charles there or the
hotel worker in jefferson city
over the dnc's desire to control our
lives
leadership is steve shabbat and jamie
rear butler writing a bill that is
supported by the members of both parties
and pursuing every option to deliver
relief to small businesses and tens of
millions of people
there's over 130 billion dollars that's
been stated already left in the ppp
we should be targeting that money to the
industries and businesses that need it
we now know
as a result of the last several months
exactly which businesses we need to be
helping where the biggest pain is where
the biggest struggles are
and those employees of those businesses
we know where that is we can target this
relief
the money sitting there what are we
doing nothing continue to play politics
with all this
enough is enough i think we need to stop
attacking the economic
freedom that this country is built on we
need to stop attacking the work ethic
that makes us the most successful nation
on earth we need to stop attacking the
livelihoods of the people who sent us
here to work for them
and american small businesses and
american people deserve
so much more with that thank you very
much and i think
chairwoman cheney is going to come and
also do some
more further introducing folks thank you
thank you blaine uh i'd now like to um
introduce
uh a young woman who uh her name is
sarah white she's the chief operating
officer of three locations of the lost
dog
cafe operating not far from here
in virginia and she's going to talk
about the real world
impact of the decision by the speaker
not to move forward on the needed
assistance for the american people
so with that sarah i'd like to introduce
you
as a restaurant consultant my job used
to be about running more smoothly
making money often in hopes of operating
another location
over the course of the pandemic my jobs
become how to reduce costs to keep your
doors open
unfortunately that means reducing staff
as we all try to stay open
we're having to not only lay off workers
but reduce hours of everyone left
it's heartbreaking to see our restaurant
families being torn apart
as we lose people who have been with us
for many years the knowledge that not
only will there be no christmas gifts
for them this year
but that they will struggle to pay their
rent and buy groceries is taking a toll
ppp funding was a lifesaver in the
spring it allowed us to
retain all of our staff increased
training it helped with implementing so
many safety standards for our guests
that we continue to use today
our hope is that congress will pass some
desperately needed funding
to allow us to bring back all of our
staff remain at levels to get through to
the other side of this tunnel
we're here begging for our lives please
help us keep our restaurants open
thank you sarah and just to remind
everybody where does the money go
to the employees it provides them to be
able to go forward
it goes to small businesses pay for rent
utility
instead of being like the hundreds and
thousands that have closed permanently
it gives them hope for a future as the
vaccine progresses
with that let's take a few questions yes
ma'am
the president has a right for every
legal challenge to be heard
he has a right to go the supreme court
with it yes
yes next question
speaker pelosi was notified i was not
i'm asking for an fbi briefing now but
if she knew
and maintained swalwell on intel
wrong he is a national security threat
he was put on in his second year i will
tell you as a leader
intel committee is treated differently
why
because those who serve on intel get
information that members do not
for the republican side the leader
republican leader points there for the
democrat side
the democrats appoint there if you spend
the last four years in
intel worried about foreign intrusion
adam schiff knew as well to allow
eric swalwell to sit inside a skiff
where you do not bring your phones you
do not bring your watch
because what is the discussed he puts
the threat of everybody else of what
they're talking about as well
why did she allow him to stay on that
committee and let's hope she does not
in the next congress either
the democrat leader appoints the
democrat
side the question rises
when did she know why did she keep them
the same question at adam schiff
did anybody approach nancy pelosi
to lobby to put a person on their second
term
in the minority on intel committee
that's a question after no
then the next question will arise why
did the democrats pull out of a
bipartisan
task force on china after they agreed
they would
this just raises so many more questions
eric swalwell should take it upon
himself to resign from intel
why did eric swalwell knowing what he
knew
after he was warned by the fbi he didn't
go to them they went to him
why did he challenge the director of
intel
john radcliffe when he just briefed the
american public
on the rise of china's spying why did he
challenge that and take china's side and
not america
that begins to raise a question too and
i would hope the democrat
leadership would raise a question for
them
it's an easy one to answer for me he is
a national risk that should not serve on
the intel committee
suawell was swindled and he should be
against china now instead of keep
standing up for them
yes
you get briefed about it but if you're
on the intel committee i think that
would be
appropriate you know what's interesting
to me this indep
individual actually bundled money to
help him get elected
this individual within a china spy went
as far down into mayor's offices
as well this is something that you have
the director of intel
john radcliffe warned the american
public about is true but the only person
that went to challenge it
and to take china's side was eric
swalwell
yes ma'am
no i actually support the plan that's
actually more money that is supported by
the president supported by the
republican leaders
that would actually go to more people
help more people in a time of need would
put more than 300 billion dollars
for small business would allow us to use
money that's already appropriated
so be fiscally responsible at the same
time and to do that now
the only person is holding it up is the
same person that's held it up for the
last four months speaker pelosi
yes
yes it easily could get done
which ball i'm not attending today
next question thank you all very much
thank you so much
[Music]